[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to off the
record where we talk about whatever we
want and uh i
last night i was trying to go to sleep
last night i was trying to study
uh for jk news so i was like trying to
understand all this information that
we're about to present today
and my phone just kept going off and i
did not answer it put on do not disturb
and this morning i woke up to 432
text messages because steve bart and joe
were going off about omg and about
what invite what is going on me and gio
were talking a lot too
like you guys don't even know what
crypto is barely
[Music]
i know that i give you money for it it's
always because we have a life and we do
fun [ __ ] yeah like really fun
stands for oh my god yeah oh my god oh
my god
oh my god oh my god you guys are so lame
we knew we knew that
stupid anyway well i want to be as
popular
as cassie what are you guys talking
about so that story short if this was
rocky the movie in the beginning omg was
doing good had a lot of hope
and so everyone bought into it and then
rocky gets the [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of
them
for like a good so
goes to the [ __ ] hospital is [ __ ]
paralyzed and he's about to they
literally bury his ass somehow [ __ ]
rocky sticks his hand through the dirt
he's like i'm alive and he started
coming back up and now he's training for
his next big fight and last night we
kicked mr t's ass
beat the [ __ ] out of it beat the [ __ ]
out of him punches right just this
morning
no no we're gonna be rocky we're so
chill yeah
but that's uh we're at and rocky looks
stronger
and better than ever and there's more
people looking at this [ __ ]
i don't understand rocky has a reason to
be in the ring now i don't understand
these boomer
references can we get more like like
younger it's like it's like it's like
no it's not an air bud remember airbus
airbud i love airboat
it's like airborne airbud he's going to
lose the basketball game everyone's real
sad
that's still an old reference wait what
he's going to lose a basketball game
you're all quoting like 80s 90s movies
no but you got to think about
poor air bud gonna lose a basketball
game and then don't they have like 20
earbuds yeah oh yeah that's true they
made like an air bud goes to space
i have a modern reference it's like it's
like when three ninjas went to japan
thank you thank you yeah thank you
exactly
when the karate kid the first one not
the one with jackie chan yeah yeah
karate can we check each other okay it's
like back to the future
where oh right yeah there you go all
right i get it boomers i get it
but yeah that's why we're so excited
that's why there's 400 something
uh text because we're just like we're
i'm like i'm just lit it's mainly joe
and steve talking cause i don't really
know as well oh true yeah it was mainly
john steve
just learning we're just backing just
one mainly one coin we have a lot of
faith in one
one of the coins but i always have
always will they're
diversified in many different y'all are
loyal yeah you know
a lot of people keep saying you guys got
to do crypto talk crypto talk and i'm
like man
i think crypto talk there's so many
different levels to it because the first
level
is understanding how it works
all the basics and then the second level
like blockchain so it's like
so like it's like in the movie karate
kid right when he's just like waxing all
the way
there it is and he's just getting it
yeah we're jacking on jack it off
we've been doing all these chores and
[ __ ] for this old japanese man and
they're like why
you getting me doing all this free work
and he goes wax on [ __ ]
and he's like oh [ __ ] you've been
teaching me is that the second level
yeah well that's that and then once you
learn a little bit then all of a sudden
you get your ass beat and then it's like
you have like seasonal depression
because of [ __ ] cryptocurrency
you had seasonal depression i don't know
some people do there's people that die
i mean that kill themselves because like
they
they don't understand it and then yeah
it's like yeah yeah yeah
you don't understand something it's like
gambling yeah yes gambling you're just
putting your money on a roulette wheel
and you're like hopefully it's black or
hopefully it's red
if you understand it like how i
understand the roulette table it's no
longer gambling
[Laughter]
bart's got it figured out so there's the
reds and the blacks
and then there's the greens that no one
knows about that sign not as good odds
when there's blood or if you flip a coin
yeah when are we going to vegas dude
soon
let's go i thought you guys didn't want
to go no we do want to move there
permanently
oh i thought you want to do you guys
want to go to play
no how cute i just got a glimpse into
like seven-year-old
joe knocking on the door you guys want
to play and then we say no
we're like [ __ ] no loser did you guys
ever used to do that when you lock on
your friends
uh dora then their mom opens up they're
like kente mark about to play
and then she'll be like he has to finish
his homework first you gotta come back
later
and i'm like damn that's cool i didn't
have friends yeah um
and i no nobody came to my house and i
couldn't go to anyone's house now
usually we would call each other up or
they're like
hey my mom won't let me go outside but
come over and then
ask her oh that's funny and then don't
be like can joseph come out to play my
mom will be like
yeah fine how cute i'll be getting in
trouble and shovel it
i'm like for me i'm like in the back
[ __ ] mopping some [ __ ]
and then i hear ding dong can bart come
out and play
and my mom's like buy my home
cinderella i pictured your mom like you
go to that house can bark come to play
and then she'll be like come on in
there's homework oh yeah
she's also done that
that was the most traumatizing birthday
i had was my fifth grade one that's
why i remember it because my friends
came over and then she made all of us do
homework and then nap time after
what in fifth grade grade yeah in fifth
grade we're already like skateboarding
and doing normal [ __ ]
who's your friends that day they all
told me the next day at school that
they're never coming over for birthday
oh she [ __ ] you
and my mom uh she because she was like
oh cool you're getting older so this is
like a
special day for you nap time the whole
day i wore a dress shirt and a tie too
oh [ __ ] so like we're all hanging out
we're [ __ ] playing basketball in
my driveway and i have to wear a dress
shirt and a tie and [ __ ] slacks
and so if even when my friends showed up
at my house
like everyone's under regular [ __ ]
shorts and t-shirts whatever right and
then they're like
barb why the [ __ ] are you dressed like
this i'm like oh my
little torture there fifth grade was
this them before or after you bowed to
her to thank her
for oh that's in the morning that's in
the morning yeah she was like
fifth grade dad that sucks because that
fifth grade you're trying to be [ __ ]
cool you know at fifth grade
yeah and then by by fifth grade you
already want you're you're trying to be
a man and [ __ ] you're trying to do math
the [ __ ] you know yeah you're trying
to like date girls and like go to school
dances and [ __ ] not with a mom like mine
no bart's trying to play the cello
apparently [ __ ]
hey where's his mom for his birthday
good lord
yeah oh no we were like we're like
playing like wwe
in our wwf at the time in my living room
and like i'm the only guy in a [ __ ]
uh dress shirt
and tie and i'm like all sweating and
celloest yeah
exactly you have to nap in a dress shirt
and tie too
yeah okay time for lunch and my mom
sucks at cooking so she made food
and i'm like can we just go eat out like
a normal family but then she wanted to
make food she goes no these kids
probably had nothing nutritious their
whole lives
finally i could make them i don't know
like a sauteed ginseng or something
we ate something nasty and then uh
we did homework and then we went to
sleep and your friends told you the next
day they're never coming over
oh my god birthday birthday cake
situation like that
was it lillian and bart i don't remember
that specific year but probably
something like that
donate your presents to kids in front of
you um no what she would do is she would
accept kit like presents from
um her friends for like christmas or
something and she's like oh thank you
and we
put it in this closet that i never get
to open it hits me open it and i get to
go oh cool that's exactly what i wanted
and then we put it in the closet and
then we repackage and give it to the
kids
yeah exactly your mother you have a
healthy relationship with her i just
roast her i think now it's just revenge
for like the last
damn i just roast the [ __ ] out it's just
crazy how someone can even come up with
these ideas
yeah well it blows my mind it's not
because she really goes
with confucius like laws and teaching
what does that do with wearing a tie
under
fifth grade birthday no a lot because
she gave me i know people that follow
confucius
she makes up her own [ __ ] is what i'm
saying sometimes people are just being
[ __ ]
how is that confucianism no no so she
follows it but then she like
like she takes it very literally she's
remixing everything
i think she invents [ __ ] i think so
that's how a lot of religions are
she's buddhist and she makes up crazy
things
that fit her whole wars were fought
because of christianity they're like
god told me to do this interpretations
of christianity too being different like
oh i think it's like this
and then they fight over that it's crazy
because i was like
okay if you have if you had like normal
friends right and family friends and
they had their
own birthdays and stuff she came up with
her own thing because she didn't learn
from them no
because it would make way more sense if
all of your cousins and
and your family did things a certain way
that was different
like y'all you guys were like amish or
something right something strange
and they're like that would be really
weird mom is like chinese
yeah no they're they can't watch it
they're not yeah yeah
you can talk [ __ ] if people aren't
watching yeah yeah yeah they'd have to
hand crank the wi-fi for way too long
but like but like let's say
yeah i guess the only closest person
would be your aunt who tried to marry
your cousin to you
what but um everyone else like i'm just
wondering
she's very creative right because she's
coming up with these things out of thin
air
yes she's not even doing it can i have
some context on that please yeah
the stories don't sound like they're
from the modern day they sound like
they're from centuries
so this was i don't know when probably
like fifth sixth or seventh or eighth
grade but i used to go to taiwan every
summer
to stay with family and uh
i think this one was like 13 or 14 or
15. yeah so when we
we're staying over in family and i don't
know why but nap time is a big [ __ ]
thing on my mom's side of the family
clearly for your birthday
[Music]
and in taiwan there's a huge japanese
influence because of uh the occupation i
think during world war ii
so during nap time we have like a nap
room that's like
heated floors you sleep on the floor
yeah we all sleep on the floor so dude
i like your family i want to come over
except for this part i love napping on
the floor
we're all sleeping on the floor i'm
sleeping on the floor my cousin who is
probably
eight she's a girl sleeping on the floor
my mom's sleeping on the floor
my aunt's sleeping on the floor i'm
trying to sleep and then you just hear
my mom and my aunt having like whispers
and gossiping
i'm like man these [ __ ] shut the [ __ ]
up but then i started hearing what
they're saying and then they're pretty
much saying like
hey you know how both of us have like
failed marriages and then they're like
yeah like you got a divorce i got a
divorce
he's like man it's tough out here for
our family we got it we got to keep it
within the family and then i'm just like
listening like because you said also
like nobody understands us
no one understands this i'm just like
sleepy and i'm like what the [ __ ]
going on
and then they're like what if bart
marries
uh the cousin and then i'm just like i'm
like this
with my eyes open i'm like what the [ __ ]
why is your life a sitcom
and then they're like yeah if you
remember keeping within the family this
is how they do it back in the days you
know so we don't have to
outside interference and we don't have
we don't have any divorces anymore
we can watch them [ __ ] y'all are the
lannisters
over there yeah so i'm [ __ ] sleeping
right i'm sleeping on the [ __ ]
this cushion that we have on the floor
then i can start
feeling pressure coming closer to me no
because both my mom and my aunt are some
of them are
[ __ ] crawling over because they don't
want to wake anyone else up so they're
[ __ ]
and i could just feel like that thing
kind of move a little bit grown-ass
women crawling on the floor i [ __ ]
got them i can't pretend like i'm
sleeping
hey and they wake me up and they're like
would you want to marry your cousin
oh my god and i'm like what the [ __ ]
that's the story what did you say though
i'm like please please thank you no of
course not i'm like what the [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] crazy i'm like were you
whispering but yelling what the [ __ ] are
you [ __ ]
well try i'm trying to also not be
disrespectful enough to get my ass beat
oh so it's a it's a fine line yeah
that's hard how old are you
i'm like 13 or 14. wow i have to ask
this question
for the opportunity for me to marry my
cousin
i i i will think about it but i don't
think and also trying to prevent myself
from not throwing up first
i'm like look at the [ __ ]
eight-year-old child there
does your family have a bidet out in
asia no
that's the part that we didn't get the
japanese influence yet
oh because when we went to japan i think
that was one of the best things
that got us to get bidets all over we
have bidets in almost every single
bathroom at our house now
that's why this video is brought to you
by hellotushy.com baby
it is freaking awesome so they sent me a
package
i got to set one up yeah and i would
have to say
what is it a bidet yes my booty has been
very
very fresh like it's pretty nice
nice you know what they gave me like
panda toilet paper too
they gave me cloths yeah they gave me a
t-shirt all this stuff
it's it's pretty cool yeah if you've
never used a bidet before it's night and
day difference i would say it goes like
tissue paper it's obviously the worst
when you don't wipe at all and i don't
know anyone that does that anymore
but you don't wipe then you wipe and you
have wet wipes
but they is the best the straight cleans
your butthole like you just took a
shower it feels really good
really fresh you feel confident like i
can stick my butt in her face after i
poop and i feel really confident do that
it doesn't smell so if you're looking
for confidence in the rear end area
give this bidet a try please yeah um
what i don't know yeah so so it says
here for years bidets have been
available but
hideously expensive costing thousands of
dollars
not anymore yup the hello tushy modern
bidet attachment
is here to democratize the blessings
bestowed by bidets and
offer clean balls to everyone peasants
can get one
yeah somebody wrote that down i know i
love that yeah
stream of fresh water for just seventy
nine dollars
that is pretty cheap for the the bidets
yep true yep the first time you guys
ever use biddeford i got to give the
call to action too
just because uh this you guys are going
to love this go to hellotushy.com
off the record to get ten percent off at
hellotushi.com
off the record and also if you're shy if
you're if you're shy back there
uh every hello tushy bidet attachment
comes with a 60-day risk-free guarantee
and 12-month warranty
that's right 10 off baby hellotushy.com
records you say the differences like
night and bidet
i like that it is powerful what are you
going to say casey hired me
the first time you guys ever used a
bidet was it like
like life-changing or was it like
something you had to gradually get into
because like i was really
nervous about using a video for me it
was in japan and
i was kind of nervous too because i just
imagined for some reason like
some like boot camp drill instructor
with the host
[ __ ] and so i was like man this guy's
gonna [ __ ] me up
and i press the button and it's like
this gentle warm stream and i'm like
oh no nice music sometimes
and the seats won i've always my my
family friends always had it i just
never
i never realized why we didn't i don't
know the bathrooms have an outlet next
to the toilet
it's like that's the only that's the
thing that stopped happening getting all
the
outlets in our house just to have the
bidet there and not like have an
extension cord like
travel because i was like this close to
getting one and then i was like you have
to have an outlet by your toilet i was
like oh [ __ ]
well i exploded.com there was no outlet
involved there's battery operating nope
no electricity oh that's tight really
what power is it
water wow i first experimented with a
bidet in vegas
and i was very confused by it because i
did enjoy it
but i didn't think i was kind of nice
forward or back i was facing back i was
facing the toilet
that's the way it is around like that
like a cool kid in school
yeah yeah i sit like that i'm a really
cool guy in the toilet
[Laughter]
they got those ones in europe too like i
don't it's kind of different it's not
it almost looks like a separate toilet
with the faucet on it it looks like a
really short drinking fountain
yeah that one's crazy it's like it's
like the bellagio water show
have you tried that one yep it was at
the um
hotel we stayed at in the bellagio i'm
too nervous how do you use that
i don't know i just experimented well
how did you use it i sat
i just ran my ass on it did you use your
hands to clean too or no
oh no i used paper afterwards i just i
just blasted it with the water
yeah and i was like that's a lot of
freaking water bro dude i stayed in a
hostel in denmark
and we had to share a bathroom and this
cat was taking a shower for so long i
had to be so bad i had to pee in my own
sink
i hope nobody worked like uses the thing
to watch after
well you could rinse it yeah i did but
still i don't feel confident about it
being very clean
i mean it's not your face you know like
those french bidets or those european
styles
the thing is you got to get up and walk
over
the process is the funniest part because
it's like your pants around your ankles
you get up
and you gotta wobble like a penguin to
the next bidet and you have to sit down
and then turn that one on that's true
yeah are you supposed to sit on it
i don't know i don't know if i used it
right
i got maybe i should watch a tutorial on
youtube did the bidet penetrate your
body
no okay the one in the office penetrated
your body though
oh yeah the vortex vortex that is an
enema
really yeah that one's strong i don't
know i'm becoming a connoisseur
of the of the time you know you're
getting closer to moving past the rim
job you talk about
yeah but that's not even uh uh uh uh for
pleasure
it's for hygiene yeah it's different
it's pre-pleasure it's very different
i'm just saying when you eat a popsicle
are you sucking a dick no it's it's a
different kind of pleasure
but it sure looks like it though yeah
i'm just saying you're gonna be less
ticklish
ouch what ouch she does
sometimes she hammer [ __ ] her mouth
with it and i like that that's not when
you're watching
i is true that's for you
have you ever had a cousin that or that
try to marry you yeah
the white guy in the room like that's
the best
with that's the best we are running out
of time on jk news what do we talk about
right now i've ever heard
but yeah actually yes makes sense though
but i had a crush on him
yeah white people are very similar did
that feel
weird to you in middle school and she
told everybody the worst time she told
her friend and everything she told
everybody did she do that
she really liked because she wanted to
destroy my life apparently that's how i
felt and then steve got in trouble
why yeah well for his cousin having a
crush yeah exactly everyone's [ __ ] all
over me like i'm a cousin [ __ ] and i'm
like i'm not a cousin [ __ ] i didn't do
anything
she just likes me how close were you
guys and cousins she was my second
cousin
she got married oh that's fine i think
that's okay it doesn't matter because
the branding is cousin [ __ ]
and now everyone's gonna call me cousin
[ __ ] second cousins are still not okay
to marry
uh i know a couple that i'm married
really really you guys
talk about it now like at a family
gathering is it weird like
you used to like me does she wink at you
and lick her lips i don't talk to her
anymore i hate that [ __ ]
really no no no she's fine no no i i
haven't brought it up in a long time now
it's not a time
yeah like a family gathering and just
pouring punch right you just kind of got
wandering guys
just looking around you're just looking
around do you ever like lock eyes with
her in the room
oh [ __ ] it's her you know yes i do every
time i see her you're like i hope she
doesn't like remind you
but but unlike you i'm not like
hey remember when you like had a crush
on me when we were in school that's
weird right
like i'm like no i should probably not
talk about that right now does it sound
like you're interested in her now
yeah right [ __ ] sake bart yeah you
still want to [ __ ]
is that stirring the coffee is is that
you
is that you when you run your cousin
like hey remember when uh our parents
want us to get married
not my cousin that's weird but i do rub
it in my mom's face and my aunt's face
as much as we can oh that's good
i like it because your cousin was a kid
at the time she didn't know [ __ ] she was
just napping away right
yeah she's just mind your own business
no she was getting married off at that
moment yeah
yeah she's a third grader the same
cousin that was living with your mom
[Music]
foreign